in this course you will learn how to
build a self-driving car simulation by
making every component yourself with no
libraries this course is a great way to
learn about neural networks
you will also learn about modern
javascript techniques radu teaches this
course
he is a phd in computer science and is
one of the more creative tech youtubers
out there
hi i'm radu and welcome to the
self-driving car no libraries javascript
course it's a course where i teach you
how to make a self-driving car
duh
and we'll do it without using any kind
of libraries so that you really
understand what's going on under the
hood
now before you say anything yeah it
won't be a real car you drive outside
but making this kind of simulation is
maybe even harder than doing it for real
let me explain
in this course you learn how to
implement simple physics to move the car
in the beginning we'll control the car
ourselves using the keyboard to get the
field that we want
i'll also teach how to create a road and
how to follow the car on the road like a
drone is filming it from above
we'll then simulate some sensors on the
car these sensors work by raycasting and
detect if the car is too close to the
side of the road or to other cars in
traffic
to implement these we'll use a formula
for segment intersection
don't worry i'll explain the math in a
nice visual way you'll see
we'll implement collision detection
using the same segment intersection
formula it's great it works with any
orientation and can even support other
shapes as well
now all of these are things you don't
have to worry about if you're working
with real hardware
the world gives you the best physics
better than any simulation there are
plenty of roads to drive on we don't
need to create them ourselves and
nowadays cars have a bunch of sensors
that tell if something is touching or
around the car
of course if you want to build all of
these yourself then yeah making the
simulation is easier but what are you
elon musk
anyway the second half of the course is
the really interesting part
you learn how to create and visualize a
neural network
an algorithm inspired by the biological
neural networks in our brains
i'll briefly explain how our brains work
to the best of my ability and teach you
how to code something similar ourselves
then we'll optimize the brain by trial
and error
yeah to keep things simple we just try
randomly generating brains until we get
something that works
we'll parallelize this step and use
hundreds of cars at once to save time
by the way this is something you can't
do with real hardware unless you're
really really rich and that's why car
companies use simulations to train their
neural networks as well
i'll also teach you a basic genetic
algorithm to optimize faster
but don't expect anything too fancy
this entire system is complex but i made
it so that each component is relatively
simple in and of itself
i made this course keeping in mind my
high school days back in romania so the
knowledge you get from school should be
enough depending on the curriculum
we'll work with javascript because it's
so easy to get started
you just need an editor and a browser
which you probably have already
i'll teach you many modern javascript
techniques so this course is perfect if
you want to become a better coder as
well as a machine learning expert
now javascript is not the best choice
when doing artificial intelligence but
since we're not using any libraries it
doesn't really matter
if you want to learn these in a more
useful language like python then come
study at carellia university of applied
sciences there i teach this same thing
in python as well and we also study
machine learning libraries and even use
hardware components
but now start your engines because the
course is about to start
i'll first teach you how to implement
the car driving mechanics
you learn to make a car that moves like
this
it's not really that hard you'll see
i'll refresh your memory with some basic
physics and trigonometry and you'll be
able to code this in no time
we begin with this simple project setup
we have three files right here
index.html main.js and style.css and
they're all empty for now
and i'm using visual studio code to
write this
and on the right i have
google chrome and
you need to have the developer tools
open there it's really important
so if you plan to follow along have a
similar setup you can use another editor
if you want but i recommend this visual
studio code nowadays
let's begin
with basic html
in the head i'm going to write a title
for this and it's going to be a
self-driving car
no libraries
really
everything here is going to be just
written by us
i'm linking now the
style sheet
and
let me close the head and in the body
i'm going to define a canvas
we are mostly going to use this canvas
in this project here i'm also linking
the javascript file
like this
and we are done with the html for the
moment at least to refresh the page
and
not much happens really
it says here self-driving car no
libraries in the in the tab of the
browser but nothing appears in the page
itself
apparently
if you open these elements you will see
that the canvas is actually there it's
just transparent
and the body actually has
this orange small margin there
i want to get rid of that margin and
also make this canvas visible somehow so
let's go to this style css next
and write some styles
i will remove the margin for the body
and let's make the body have a dark gray
background
overflow to hidden
and i'm gonna use text align to center
for now
overflow is important otherwise we might
get the scroll bar coming if the canvas
is too big and i don't want that and i
want everything to align to center
in the middle of the page
now my canvas should have a different
colored background maybe we set it to
light gray like this
and save
refresh
and now you can actually see the canvas
without needing to inspect these
elements right here i'm gonna move back
to the console it's probably the most
important thing in the developer tools i
want my canvas to stretch the full
screen vertically so i'm going to go in
main.js right here and i'm going to get
a reference to our
canvas with id
my canvas we defined previously and i'm
gonna set the height of this to be the
full
window
inner height like this
and
the width is going to be
just 200 pixels it will be like a road
going upwards we'll need the space on
the side to draw the neural network
later
now if i save this and refresh you can
see it appearing there exactly how we
want it
let's next pretend that we
have a car and we want to draw it on the
canvas
to
draw on the canvas we first need to get
the drawing context we will just use the
2d context in this whole project so i'm
going to have a reference to this canvas
context right here in the ctx and it's
going to contain all the methods we need
to draw the things that we need to draw
in this project
and if we would have a car we would say
something like this let's get the car
at
for example
100 x
100 y and the car maybe has a 30
width and 50 height all of these are in
pixels
and let's draw the car
using this context
but we don't have the car yet this is
the thing that we are going to need to
define next the car object
and we are going to do this
first by going inside of
index.html here and preparing to import
a new file
car js like this
and now i'm going to add a new file here
car js
in here
i'm going to
say
class
car so we are defining our car class and
the constructor for this class is going
to have four different parameters so we
have here the x and the y and a width
and a height
so
these are properties of the car where we
want it to be and how big should the car
be and we are going to store these as
attributes inside of the object like
this so that the car remembers where it
is and how big it is
now
remember we also had this draw
being called so that draw was a method
and it looks something like this it gets
a context as a parameter
and in here
we
begin path and we are going to draw a
car as a simple rectangle for now the
rectangle is going to start
at
an x and y location so i'm going to use
this dot x minus this dot width divided
by two so the x of the car is going to
be the center inside the car and it's
going to have
parts in front behind
left and right so on the top bottom left
and right the y value i subtract
half the height
so here
we also need to specify what is the
width and height of this rectangle like
this
and ask the context to
fill it like so
and if i'm going to save this and
refresh the page you can see the card
there or at least a black rectangle for
now the car is here at 100 100. so on
computer screens the y-axis actually
goes downwards and the zero zero point
relative to this canvas is actually
right up here now this is really boring
as such i'm going to teach you next how
to move the car using the keyboard arrow
keys
so for now let's just pretend that we
have here some controls like
this controls is equal to
new
controls
and
let me link
a new file
here in index
controls js
and also create
controls
js
and we will do a similar thing as
previously so we need a class for these
controls
and the constructor the controls object
will have four different attributes
one of it
will
know if it's going forward
one of it for the left
one of it for the right
and one for the
reverse like this and i set them to
false initially but these will change
depending on what you press on the
keyboard so i'm next going to define a
method for
adding so called keyboard listeners so
that we have a piece of code that checks
whenever we press a key or release a key
so i'm going to call here add keyboard
listeners
and this is going to be
a method inside of the controls class
like so
the reason i put here this hashtag in
front is because this is a private
method you can't access this from
outside of this controls class and you
shouldn't it's its own responsibility so
how does this add keyboard listeners
look like
well
we will add a key down event to the
document
and set this
to be equal to
this arrow function i will explain arrow
functions in just a second but
let's implement this first so
depending on the key that was pressed
if this was the arrow left key
we are going to set this left
to true
and break
and do the same thing for the arrow
right key
like this
the arrow up key
for forward
and the arrow down key
for reverse
and that's it but we also need to know
when we release a key so i'm going to
actually copy this code
here
like so
and this is going to be
on key
up
and all of these things are going to be
set to false
i want to debug if all of this code that
we wrote works so i'm going to put here
a console
table
this i'm going to output this entire
object
into the console in a table format
when i press a key and when i release a
key i save the file refresh and every
time you press something like now i'm
pressing the up key
now i release the up key
now i'm pressing the down key
i released the down key
left
and right
you can see the values in the console
have changed so this code seems to be
working
great but
why is it working so let's look a little
bit up here and
this part of the code may be a little
strange to you if you're not familiar
with this arrow function notation this
is actually the same thing as writing
here
function
of event like this so we say that on key
down
this is the function that you are going
to call but if you write it like this
this
here stops referring to the object here
to the controls object it actually
refers to this function right here and
if i undo and use this arrow function
notation
this continues to refer to this object
right here so it's a difference in how
these two type of functions work in
javascript and it's convenient to have
it in this way
now controls are triggering but let's
move the car with them
so i'm going to go to car js
and we are going to write here an update
method
this update method
is going to check if
the controls
say forward
let's just move the car
upward so that means y minus equals two
remember that y increases downwards on a
computer
and if these controls are
reverse
then
we add 2 to y so that it goes downwards
now this won't do anything just yet we
need to go to main js here and start to
animate
so
i'm going to write here animate
and define
an animate function like this
and inside here i'm going to update the
car
and then i'm going to draw the car
using this code we had previously like
this and call request animation frame
with animate like so
request animation frame calls the
animate method again and again many
times per second it gives the illusion
of movement that we want
now we can save the file
refresh the page
and when i press down
something happens
so the car updates
and redraws itself but all the past
positions of the car are still there and
if i press up now
it takes a while but then it reaches
again the top part and you start seeing
it again but it leaves this black trail
there so
we need to fix this and actually we need
to fix something else as well if i'm
gonna resize this console here you will
see that this canvas here doesn't
stretch
to fill the screen vertically anymore
this bothers me but it's it's great
because we can fix both of these issues
by
moving this piece of code from here here
when you resize the canvas in this way
it means that it also becomes cleared
so if i refresh now and press the down
key the car is actually seemingly moving
and it doesn't leave that trail anymore
also if i resize this console here
it
looks proper you might have to click on
the screen here before you can press the
top and down arrows sometimes these
listeners don't activate unless you
click inside the page
okay problem now is that
this doesn't move like a car at all we
need to work on this cars don't move so
that you press on something and then
immediately stop i'm going to go to the
car constructor here and give the car
a speed attribute
and an acceleration
value like this
and here instead of changing the y value
and forward we are going to say that the
speed will increase
by the acceleration
like this
and i'm going to copy this
here below
but with minus
and here i will say
this dot y
minus equals
this dot speed
i save the file
refresh the page i press down
i press up
okay
we need to stop the car from going too
fast and implement some friction
so
i'm going to go here and say
max speed equals to something like three
and a friction of
let's say
0.05 like this
and in the update method i'm going to
move here
and say
if the speed is more than this max speed
this speed becomes max speed we are
capping it
the same if the speed is less than minus
this max speed
but in reverse i want the card to be not
as fast i'm just gonna divide by two
here
if it's less than this then i'm gonna
cap it to be minus max speed divided by
two maybe you want to have a max reverse
speed or something declared on top
feel free to do it i think it's overkill
also there's no such thing as a negative
speed like what we have here
the negative sign is just to indicate
that the car is going backwards
luckily this is not a course on physics
otherwise i might get in trouble for
this
next thing we do is
check if the speed is greater than zero
i will decrease it
by the friction like this and if the
speed is less than zero
then speed
increases
by the friction
like this now i save the file refresh
the page press down
and the car is moving
i released and it slowed down a bit and
then it stopped i'm pressing now up
and i release
you can see it's still moving a little
bit before it stops
and i think that this feels
quite okay but at the moment the car is
only going forward and backward and the
left and right don't do anything
one small issue though
let me see if i can get it to happen
okay if you release in just the right
way you will see this let me zoom in
a little bit
more
see the car is actually
always moving it's constantly moving no
matter if we press a key or not actually
if we don't press any key
and it's moving by by a very very very
small value and that's because
if the speed is not equal to zero
exactly then this friction is gonna
bounce it around and eventually it's
going to move it forwards by a very very
small value
so
to fix this we can actually write here
if
the speed has a absolute value that is
less than the friction
just have it become zero like so and
this is gonna work no need to test
anymore let's implement the
left and right
controls next and say as before if we
press left x
gets
-2
and if we press right
x gets plus two notice how i implement a
basic thing first and make it more
advanced afterwards
i really want you to get the idea that
everything can be improved but that you
can make a complex system even with easy
components i mean by the end of this
course you will have a self-driving car
no matter if it moves like now or if we
implement better physics into it
now if i refresh
and
zoom out a bit
now if i press left and right
the car moves in a very very
funny
non-realistic way but this is actually
how cars move in some games for example
so if you want to make
a self-driving car for a game
then this might be enough for you
but i'm gonna teach you how to do better
than this and
actually i don't like this for one
important reason
we are breaking the laws of
physics we have here the value for this
maximum speed
and we can reach that maximum speed by
going forward like this but if i press
right now i'm actually going faster than
the maximum speed but diagonally because
i'm going the maximum speed vertically
and a little bit to the left in this
case so
this is bad for many reasons
let me teach you how to fix it
we are going to go up here and define
an angle let's set it to zero and here
instead of doing this we are actually
going to modify
the angle to increase by 0.03
for example
and here we have angle
minus equals 0.03
so this angle works according to the
unit circle but in our case the value of
0 is upwards so it's a unit circle that
is
rotated 90 degrees counterclockwise if
you will
but keep this image of the unit circle
in mind of the rotated unit circle in
mind because this is going to be our
coordinate system for making
rotations
speaking of which we can make a very
easy rotation like this using the canvas
context
first we save the context
then we translate to the point where we
want the rotation to be centered at
and now i'm going to tell the context to
rotate by minus this angle
next i'm going to remove here
this dot x and this dot y because we're
already translating to that point
and one last thing we need to do is here
add a call to context
restore because otherwise on each frame
of the animation we are going to
translate and rotate and translate and
rotate and translate and rotate and this
is going to do some infinite series of
translations and rotations that will
look pretty funny maybe but not what we
want
so let me save this
refresh and now when i press left
my car
rotates
counterclockwise and when i press right
it rotates clockwise so we have
something there
it's not yet good it's more like
like a tank
that can rotate in place
cars can't do that but
more importantly if i rotate like this
and press the down key
my car just moves
downwards in this weird way and this is
not correct and same goes for upwards we
want the car to actually move in the
direction of this angle
so i'm going to implement this
based on the unit circle again i'm going
to make x go
minus the sine of the angle
times the speed so unit circle has a
radius of one this sine is between minus
one and one so we need to scale this by
the value of the speed as well and then
for y
we do the same thing but with the cosine
here
according to the unit circle now we
don't need this anymore
i can save the file
refresh the page
rotate to the left
press down
and look at that
the car is moving
properly
and
i can actually start to feel
like i'm driving a car
but
backwards
it's flipped like look at this if i
press backwards and right
the car turns left
that's not how it happens in in real
life
so we need to fix that and also this
rotating in place next i'm going to just
put here
if this speed is not zero
i'm going to calculate
a flip
so i'm going to say the value of this
flip is one or minus one depending on
the speed so that i can flip the
controls backwards
and if if this is the case
then
here i can just multiply
by the flip
if the flip is positive one then this
doesn't do anything so when the car is
moving forward when it has a positive
speed
then this won't change but when we go
backwards what essentially happens is
these
signs are flipped
so let me close this here and test again
now if i press left and right nothing
happens because our speed is zero
but if i go backwards and to the right
it goes just the way i want it
and now i'm doing these kind of
i'm trying to
change the direction in the car
similar to how
it would happen
when driving the car
play around with it and if there's
something you don't like change it
especially if you're good at physics but
if you're not you can try using
libraries here as well box 2d is a
really good one i think
but i'm happy with this there's one
thing that we don't need anymore that's
the debug here in the controls i'm just
going to remove this because now i'm
confident that the controls work as i
want them to
i'm going to save this file and in car
this update method starts to be
quite big
and more things are going to be coming
here later
so
one good thing would be to
group all this code here in a separate
method i'm going to cut it and the
method is going to be called
move because that's what this is doing
it's moving the car
according to the controls and
the move method is going to be a private
method it has the
hashtag there and i paste the code that
we had previously in here i saved this
refresh
and everything still works
as previously
i'll show you how to do the road next
so in index.html
we are going to say here
that we include
road
js
a new file that we have to also create
here
road
js like this
and in here we are going to start to
write our road
class
so very similar as before we have a
constructor here and i want the roads to
be centered around an x value
and have a
width
now these are going to be attributes
that the road should remember and
actually
i want it to have also a number of lanes
so
let's write here something like this
and
define here a lane count that has a
default value of 3 for now at least
it's useful to have a few more
attributes here that we can pre-compute
and use later in our calculations so for
example
we can have a value for left
that is half the width
less than x
and a right that is half the width more
than x
and i want the road to go infinitely
upwards and downwards so let me just
define here a constant for
infinity a really large number there's
actually one in javascript already but i
found that when drawing things with
infinite size
weird things happen so let's just have a
very very big value here
like this and our top is going to be
minus infinity and bottom is going to be
plus infinity remember that
y on the computer grows downwards
now to draw the road i'm gonna make a
draw method here similar what we had the
car drawing method and i'm going to set
here a line width of 5 so a relatively
thick line
and i'm going to make it white
that's how the
lines on the road usually are
and let's begin a path
and move to
left
and
top
and the line to
left and bottom so we are now drawing
a vertical line on the left side of the
screen i'm going to copy this
below like this and i'm also going to
draw
a line
on the right side of the screen
like so
and we are done with this road js for
now
i'm going to move in the main
js file
and above where we define this car i'm
now going to say
a road is equal to a new road
centered in
half the width of the canvas so that's
going to be our center x
and it's going to have a width of the
whole canvas width i'm going to now go
down
here and
right
road draw on the canvas as well before
the car so that the road comes first and
then the car on top of it
let's now save this
refresh
and almost nothing happens but you
should be able to see here on the sides
some
white
lines there now they're exactly at the
side of the road i want to leave a
little bit of margin there so i'm gonna
make here this width smaller let's say
90 percent of the canvas width save this
and refresh and
looks better already
but we said that our road should have
some lanes right
here in the constructor the third
argument
it has by default three lanes and we
will need to make them appear as well
i'll show you
we go back down here
and i'm going to write
a simple for loop
going from 0 to
this lane count
inclusive so notice here i have less or
equals to
this lane count
and now i want to know what is the x
coordinate of
each of these
lines of these vertical lines that we
are going to draw and depending on the
lane count we will have more or less of
these
lanes but also the x values are
different
we get these using linear interpolation
i'll show you
we say here
x is equal to linear interpolation or
lerp we will write this function don't
worry it's not not complicated
and we will interpolate from left
to right so we need to get values
between left and right
according to a percentage
this percentage is going to be i divided
by
this lane count
like this think about it
this last value from here is going to be
between 0 and one when i becomes this
lane count then this is going to be one
and with all the in-between values you
just get percent values over here
so how this slurp function looks like
is
function
lerp
it's a funny name but i've seen it used
by game developers at least
and that's it
so
you have
the value of a and then the difference
between b and a
times this
percentage t
so
when t is zero this part here is zero
you only have a
when t is one
this minus a from here will cancel out
and you're just left with b so
0 and 1 or 0 and 100 percent just give
you the two end points
and for example when t is in the middle
then this difference is just
half of that difference so it's going to
move half away from a and so on it's a
really simple function and i've used it
in very many different projects so i
really recommend that you have it in
your
utilities
as well
so let's see if it works first and then
i'll move it in a utils file it doesn't
belong here we'll be using this many
times throughout this project
so here i'm going to align this part
like so but replace here left with x
value like this
and also this one
and we don't need this piece of code
anymore
closing this here and i think that we
can save and test
and look at that we have three lanes on
our road
i'll move this function now in utils
file
so let me create it
utils.js
paste it here
save the file go to index.html
include it
like this and now if i refresh
everything still works
let me go next to row js and add dashes
to the middle lines
like so
i'm going to check if
i is greater than 0 and less than this
lane count
like this and in that case i'm going to
set line dash
and i'm going to open an array
20 and 20. and this means that our dash
will have 20 pixels and then a break of
20 pixels and another dash and so on
so
let me close this otherwise for the
borders we are gonna put
line dash
equal to an empty array like that i'm
going to save this
refresh and there are the dashes
let's test also with the lane count of 4
just to see if it works
it's quite nice but you can see the car
is off center now i would like it to be
on a lane right
so
it would be useful to have a method that
tells us what is the center of a given
lane let's do it
get lane center
with the given index so this will start
from left to right starting at zero
i'm going to get a helper variable first
the line width
equal to
a width divided by the length count like
this and then using that i'm going to
say this left
plus
half the line width so i want to be
starting these in the middle of the
first lane
plus i'm going to multiply the lane
index
by the line width like this
and this is going to give us
for different line indices an offset of
line width away from the middle of the
first plane oh
not line with lane width
align with this something else it's the
thickness of the line
okay
and to test this we can go in main js
and here instead of passing this 100 for
the x of the car we can write
road
get
lane
center
and for example maybe we write here
three to put it on the rightmost lane
save this
refresh and the car is on the right lane
great let me go to the road
and
move this to have a lane count of three
again i like that value more
and now we see a problem the car is gone
it's actually here
on
on lane index
3 which is now outside the screen so
this is something you may want to have
fixed for example by going here and
using
the minimum function and saying you want
the minimum between the lane index
and
this lane count
minus one
with this
the car is going to go on the
rightmost possible lane even if you
accidentally tell it to go
more than that
but i prefer my car to be in the center
so let's put this on lane 1
here
and we'll keep it here for quite some
time
now this looks nice and
driving on this road definitely feels
feels nice
but in the future i want to detect these
borders
of the road here and also have collision
detections with them because naturally
we want the car to
to explode on an impact so
basically
it would be nice if the road object
could tell us where these borders are
and i'm gonna do that next
i'm going to go here in the road in the
constructor and i'm going to say
this borders is equal to
an array i'm going to put these borders
in an array
we now have just two left and right but
think about it maybe we want to have
highways and then you have another
border in the middle or
maybe
some complicated situation requires more
for some reason so i'm just going to use
an array and you can experiment with
different things
and the first thing in this array is
going to be a segment so
top left
bottom left points form a segment and
i'm going to make this also an array
something like this and the reason for
using arrays so much here is that our
line segment here is straight but maybe
you want to experiment with something
else like adding curves on the road
actually that would be a nice homework
for you to do
so i'm gonna keep a raise here like this
and the borders for now are just two
segments
made of
two points each
and
these are going to be here
defined like so
and i just copy this
three more times and say
top right
bottom left
bottom right
and here we have
right
i'm just going to copy this down here as
well
and here we have bottom
and i'm going to copy this
here as well
i will save this and
nothing really changed
not yet at least
because these borders are just here if
we say road
borders for example they are just in
memory and they are easy to
access
whenever we need them we just ask the
road hey where are your borders and it
can give them to us like this so the
left border here with the x of 10 and
the right border with the x of 190 and
plus minus infinity for these great but
because these borders are here now it
makes sense here at the bottom to draw
them separately because if we change
them like maybe if you're going to make
them curved this drawing here won't
reflect that
so i'm going to change this to be here
starting at 1 and going to lane count
minus 1
and i'm going to keep just the
line dash here
like this
and then i'm going to move below this
and say
context set line dash
to empty array and now i'm going to show
you a for each syntax
we are going to go through the borders
for each border
let's call it border i'm going to use
this arrow notation again and i'm going
to say
context begin the path
move to
the first point in the border
x
and the y
and do a line to the second point in the
border x
and y
stroke
and that's it now keep in mind that this
doesn't change anything so all the code
that we are writing now is just to make
everything more consistent but i will
teach you a cool trick next we're gonna
make it look like there's a camera above
the car and it's going to follow the car
as it moves on the road
so i'm going to go here to main.js
before drawing the road and i'm going to
say
save the context
and translate
nothing on x but minus the y value of
the car
and
below drawing these things i'm going to
say
restore again
like this and now if i save
my car moved up there
but if i accelerate
you can see that the car actually stands
still
unless i go left and right but the road
is the thing that's moving so what i
want to do is actually not keep the car
up there but maybe move it somewhere
down like for example
canvas
height
times 50
so this is now centering the car there
as i'm driving this feels really great
but uh maybe a better value would be
something like 0.7
because we in this way we see more of
what is ahead of the car and later when
we add traffic we want to be able to see
those things
and figure out if the car will do the
right things or not
really funny how easy this last thing
was
to add sensors to the car i'm going to
go to index.html
and include here
sensor js
save this file
and create a file called
sensor js
like this
and inside here i'm going to define my
sensor
and the constructor will take
the car
as the argument and the reason is that i
want the sensor to know where the car is
it's attached to the car and we're going
to be using the car properties to update
it
so let's store here the car and other
attributes will be
the ray count
so our sensor will cast rays in
different directions and let's just have
three of these rays for now
and then the ray
length so usually sensors like this have
a range after which they don't work
anymore so if they don't sense anything
in this 100 pixels range then they can
see beyond that
and array spread
so here i'm setting pi divided by 4 this
is the same as 45 degrees and that means
the angle that we are going to spread
these rays that are being casted by the
sensor
so i'm going to keep here also an array
called race and this is going to keep
each individual ray one by one after we
create them
i'm next going to create an update
method like this and we begin by setting
these rays to an empty array so this
arrays is what we are going to start to
populate next
and to do that i'm going to loop from
zero to this ray count
like this
and i'm going to
figure out the angle of each individual
ray and to do that i'm going to use the
lerp
function
our utility function from earlier here
that gives us a value between a and b
depending on t
right so if i go now back to sensors the
angle here is going to be
between
ray spread
divided by 2 remember the unit circle
the rotated unit circle
and minus ray spread divided by two
and
the t value
let's have it i divided by this ray
count
minus one this time because i is not
going to become equal to raycount so the
maximum value for i is this ray count
minus 1 actually need to remember this
it's quite important
and with this we can calculate the start
point for for our ray
and that's just going to be the car
x and y
like this
and an end point of the ray
for this end point i'm going to take the
car x as the starting point
and then using the unit circle i'm going
to take this angle that we made
previously and multiply it by the
the length so unit circle just one pixel
radius we won't see anything we need to
scale it up by the
array length here and we do the very
same thing with the y
but with the cosine there
instead
now with this start and end point
available i'm going to push these inside
of the array to form a segment
so notice here i'm using this way of
defining the segment
using an array here in the same way that
we used for the borders
here
in
road js the road borders are also going
to be made of segments defined in this
way it's good to be consistent like this
now we also need to
be able
to
draw
our sensor and i'm going to say draw
and we go through all of the arrays like
this begin a path
and i'm going to put a line width of
2 and i'm going to draw these rays using
yellow
i will move
to
the rays
start location
x and y so the first thing in the ray of
i array is its start location
and then
i will line to
the race and location so 1
with x and y there like that
and now i can stroke
and close these like so
i seem to be missing here curly brace
let's save this file
and now instantiate this sensor i will
go to
car
and inside the car constructor
here above the controls i think it's
it's good i'm going to say
this
sensor is equal to new sensor
of this so i'm passing the car to this
and then in the update method here i'm
also going to be
telling
the sensor to update
like this
and
in the draw
in addition to drawing the car i'm also
going to be telling the sensor
to draw
itself so the car has now the
responsibility to draw its own sensor
let's save this
refresh okay
so we see now three
lines popping out from the center of the
car like this and they're at the 45
degree angle which is good and when we
move the car
maybe this is not what you want to
happen
maybe it is what you want to happen i
don't know you can experiment with these
things but i would like the sensor to
rotate with the car
so that when the car moves the sensor
also moves but nowadays with gyroscopic
technology you could probably have this
kind of sensor as well if you if you
actually want
so to fix this it's really easy i just
add here to the ray angle
plus
this
car
angle like this and it works
as expected
let's play a little bit with these
values up here more for example let's
have
30
segments and
make them a bit
longer like this
wow
so many rays coming from there it's like
the the sun
let's actually go all the way so
pi times two
this is now spreading these rays in all
directions so all 360 degrees or pi
times 2 there let's put it to half pi
so a 90 degree angle i think i i like
that and let's try with ray count of one
we'll have a surprise here
it doesn't work
two
works just fine
but one doesn't
and the reason for that is this thing
here
this ray count minus one
if ray count is one then this becomes
zero and we can't divide by zero
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to replace this line
if this ray count is one i'm going to
just return half i want my ray to be
straight up in the middle between the
raised band otherwise i just do the
exact same thing as
previously so now it works no no
problems
and we got it to work we needed to do a
little bit of more thinking right here
because of this division by zero
let's try with more rays to see if that
still works maybe five
okay
nice now before we get them to work to
actually detect that there are some
road borders here
i want to
refactor this a little bit
so
all the code here in this update method
i'm going to cut it and i'm going to say
here this
dot private method cast
race
like this
and cast race
is going to get this code right here
this doesn't change anything everything
still works but now our update method
here is simpler and more code can go
into it and we can read it more clearly
now to be able to detect the road
borders we need to know where they are
and at the moment the sensor has no idea
we need to go to main.js
and first pass to the car update method
the road
borders
like this now i'm going to go to car js
and have the road
borders
here
like this and i'm going to take them and
pass them to the sensor update as well
so now in the sensor.js the update
method receives them as well and now we
can use them to detect with the sensor
if the road borders are closed or not
i'm gonna add here
an array for the readings
so these readings are going to be
some values for each array telling if
there is a border there or not and how
far is it now in this update method
i'm going to say readings is equal to an
empty array i initialize it here
and then i will iterate through all the
rays
like this
and
add to this readings array
a reading so
we will get readings using a new method
that we need to define
that takes a ray like this
and the borders
as parameters and now we're gonna go
down here
and write our get reading
method
with array
and the given borders
so now what i'm gonna do is check to see
where this array touches the road
borders and now we have just two borders
one on each side so one ray can only
touch both of them if the car goes off
screen like this but it's good to
consider multiple intersections anyway
especially because later we'll have
traffic and we'll handle that using this
same strategy as well what we'll do is
find all these touches and then keep the
closest one to the sensor and that will
be our reading in the same way that the
real sensor would work
so
let's see where this ray touches any
borders
these touches is gonna be an empty array
and i'm gonna go
through all the borders one by one we
just have two at the moment
but it's good to write it like this and
we say that the touch is equal to
get intersection this is going to be a
function that we will need to write it's
going to be a very useful utility
function you'll
see and the intersection will be between
the
ray of zero and the ray of one so this
is going to be
one segment
so far
and another segment
the height
road border
0 and the i road border
1 like this
now if there is a touch
we will add
to our touches
so
this get intersection function may
return null
if the segments don't intersect
so
that case nothing gets added to this
touches array
now
if we have absolutely no touches with
the given ray then that means that there
is no reading here we don't encounter
anything with this array
so i'm gonna say here return null like
this
otherwise
and now i'm gonna teach you a little bit
more modern javascript you see this get
intersection
doesn't just return
the intersection point but also an
offset
how far the point is from
this ray of zero which is pretty much
the center of the car so we do get with
this get intersection three things an x
a y and this offset value that will be
quite useful
so i just want all the offsets from
all the touches here in one array and we
can use modern javascript methods to get
that
like this
the arraymap method basically goes
through all the elements from this array
and for each element it takes its offset
now this part here returns a new array
in this case it's called offsets and
that's it we don't have to write a lot
of code to get this
result here and i think that's great
now we want to know from all of these
offsets the minimum one like if array
touches many different things
like many borders or cars will be later
when we add the traffic so we want to
know the nearest one after the ray
touches that all the other ones
don't exist basically so
we are going to get the minimum offset
using the math
minimum method this minimum method here
doesn't accept an array as an argument
but it does work with many many
different values so this dot dot dot
operator is spreading the array into
many different individual values and
finally i'm going to return
the
touch
that has this minimum offset
using this
find method here so going through all
the touches
element by element
if the offset of that touch
is equal to this minimum offset it will
return
that
touch
in this way
this code is pretty complex take a while
to look over it
but because we're using modern
javascript methods here the code is
really short so try to get used to this
syntax because you will see it
everywhere especially if you work with
react
now i'm gonna draw these readings
somehow here
in the draw method let
and is equal to
the array's
endpoint pretty much
but if there is a reading
i'm going to set end
to the value of that reading
remember the readings what comes from
this get intersection function will be
three things the x the y and the offset
so if we say this here we essentially
pass the x and y to this and and becomes
a point with an x and y
attributes
i'm gonna now make this yellow segment
until
end
right here
like so
and i still want to know where this line
would have continued i think it's nice
to visualize that so i'm going to copy
all of this
and i'm going to just make it let's say
black
and here i will draw from the
tip of where
the end of the ray
could be to this end point if it's a
reading or not if not then this is just
going to be a line that is so small you
can't see it now if i save all of this
and refresh
it works for me but it doesn't work for
you and that's because i have here in
the utility
file a secret function that i added
without telling you
sorry
let me just
indent this a little bit like so so that
you can actually see it
if you want to implement this yourself
by watching on the screen right now i
will make a separate video for this
because i think the topic is very
interesting and i have a nice way to
teach it as well but it works look when
i'm moving my car like this the rays are
going to the borders and immediately
when they are reaching the borders there
they are turning
black like so
and
only the yellow part is really
interesting and it's what we will use
later when we define the
neural network
i'll show you how to implement
collisions next
that is when the car is approaching the
side of the road here i want it to get
damaged somehow
so
there's a good news and bad news
good news is that i'm going to teach you
how to detect collisions using the
segment intersection code from
previously
the bad news is that the way that we
draw the car here by rotating the
context we actually don't know where the
corners of the car
are like what are their coordinates and
we're gonna need to figure those out
first
so in car js
i'm going to create here
a new
method and i will call this private
method
create polygon
this polygon will have a list of points
an array of points so one point per
corner of the car and great news is that
you can add more points you can have
different shapes and this method i'm
gonna teach you is going to work
so
if you look at this car right here
um
let me refresh so that it points upwards
and then we can use this distance right
here as a radius
like uh it's pretty much the same
distance no matter which of the corners
we are looking at
and the other thing that we will need to
figure out is this angle like what is
this angle knowing the width and the
height
so
this
radius
is actually very easy to get
using the hypot method here so this is
the hypotenuse of the triangle with
width and height and i'm dividing it by
2 because i just need half of it
and the angle here is a little bit more
tricky maybe
so
the tangent of this angle is actually
the width divided by the height
so we can use the arc tangent
method this a tan two method from the
math library to give us
the angle knowing the width and the
height
like this and i don't need to divide
this by two because that angle is the
same no matter how you look at it now
with these i can add my first point here
the x is going to be
the center x of the car minus
the sine
of
this car angle
minus this alpha value so i'm combining
here uh the alpha angle
and the car angle as well and i'm
multiplying these by the radius and the
same thing goes with y but here i'm
using the cosine like this
so this was the top right point and we
need to do
the next ones as well
so here let's just
add alpha
like this
next point i'm going to
keep minus alpha there but add here
math by
plus or
180 degrees
and the last one i will copy this one
from here
and change this alpha to a plus
like so and now we just return the
points
and that's it we want to update this
after we move the car
like this
so
this car will have
a polygon attribute that will be
generated in this way
and to draw the car
we can now use this polygon instead so
instead of this trick here where we
translate the rotate and then just draw
a rectangle here essentially losing the
corner points we can remove all of this
and just draw our polygon points in
order i'll show you
we do begin path
move to the first point in the polygon
like this
and now loop through all remaining
points
so notice that i'm starting here
at 1 because i already moved to the
first one previously and here i'm just
going to line to
the height polygons
x and
y like so
and i'm going to
fill
save the file refresh the page
and nothing happens
so everything still works
but
in a different way in a better way i'll
show you if we go up here for example
and just change one of these points
let's change this one by multiplying
this radius
by three
then our car will look like that
it's kind of kind of funny so we
couldn't do this previously and and now
we can do crazy things like this like
give complex shapes to our car and we
can of course add more points if we want
but i'm not gonna do that it's your job
to experiment
what i will do is teach how to do the
intersection between this car polygon
and this line segment on the right
and detect if the car is damaged or not
so
let's go up here and say
this
damaged is equal to false all cars are
not damaged to begin with
and then here after we have our polygon
i'm going to
assess damage a method that we're going
to need to write
with the road borders
so now here
let's define this
asus
damage method
given some road borders like so
and loop through all the borders
and check
if
there is an intersection between
this polygon
and the road border
of i the i wrote border then we return
true
if the code reaches here we return false
now we need to implement this
paulis intersect function here and it
will be a really useful utility function
that takes two polygons here as
parameters now notice here that this
road borders of i is actually not a
polygon it's a line
segment but it will be general enough
for it to work
so let's go now to utils.js
and i'm going to define
our
police intersect method with poly1 and
poly2
like so
we loop through all
of the points in poly1
and for each of them
we check
all the points in poly2
and we are going to see if they touch or
not using our get intersection
function from up here
so we say here poly1
of i and poly1 of i plus 1
modulo the length so this may look
tricky but all the things that i'm doing
here is i'm taking one point in the
first polygon and then the next point in
the first polygon so
i'm making segments essentially from one
point after the other
but at the end
this will give an error when we are
reaching i is equal to poly one length
minus one because adding one to that
then
it will go over the array but if we use
here the modulo operator like this
then that value will become zero and
that's actually great because the last
point in the polygon needs to connect to
the first point in the polygon like
point zero so this code solves two
things
and i will continue and put the same
thing for poly 2
with the j this time
so essentially i'm taking
all the segments that make the first
polygon and comparing them against every
segment of the other polygon and if
there is a touch
then i'm going to return true
otherwise if all of those checks have
returned null
then i will return here false so our
police don't intersect now to see if
this works i'm going to go back to my
car js
here and actually in the draw method
the first thing that i will do is see if
this is a damaged car i'm going to set
the fill style to gray color
otherwise i will set the fill style
to a black color
like this
saving
refresh
and
it changes color
and it changes color
immediately when the car touches the
border even with this complicated
shape because we are using each segment
forming this polygon and
comparing it with the border of the road
now this method is quite general
and
it works for
complicated polygons as well but it can
become slow if you have very many points
so then you would need to do some
optimization here maybe look at the
bounding boxes first or or something
like that
and it's really reliable as long as your
object doesn't move too quickly for
example like if our car would move so
fast that it could actually jump over a
border or over another car in traffic
then you would need a different
collision detection
strategy for that but we won't let that
happen and
if i zoom in here a lot i should mention
this because you may wonder
why
the car
doesn't detect a collision now and the
reason for that is that well
that line that border of the road
it's a line it's a mathematical line
which actually has no thickness
and here we're drawing it with a
relatively thick
thickness
and that's why it looks like it's
intersecting even though it's not
you could fix this if you want by
drawing the borders of the road with
actual
very thin infinitely long rectangles but
i'm not gonna do something like that
this is great for our purpose let me
zoom back out
change this car to be
a rectangle again i don't want to
keep it in this crazy shape and now in
the update method
i will
not allow it to move if it's damaged so
i'm going to say here
if not
damaged then do all these things
sensor
maybe it's good to be like that so the
sensor will still work even if the car
is damaged let's see if this has any
consequences
and if i refresh now the car is a
rectangle again and if i go to the side
of the road everything stops so now i
can play with the arrow keys
nothing happens my car is useless we
really want to take any kind of impact
seriously in this so i am rendering the
car useless at this stage now the car
works it has sensors it's detecting the
borders
and it's getting damaged on impact but
this is quite lonely don't you think
it's time to add some traffic without it
making it a self-driving car is not much
of a challenge
you just press the up arrow key and
perfect driving
so
let's add traffic next
i'm gonna go in main.js
and
up here i'm going to write
const
traffic
is equal to
and this is going to be an array of cars
pretty much i'm going to add another car
here
that is on the same lane as
our car that we were used to but i'm
going to put it in front and it's going
to be our first obstacle that we need to
avoid now here we need to update this as
well
so
i'm going to go through all the cars
in our traffic and i'm going to tell
each of them to update and keep in mind
the road borders or you can also pass
there an empty array instead of the
borders if you want the traffic to be
invulnerable to everything
but i'm gonna keep it there for now
let's see later and we need to draw
these as well
so i'm going to go here
another for loop going through all the
things
in the traffic
now we just have one thing but this is
going to be a general code
and it's going to draw each of them on
the canvas like that now i save the file
refresh the page and there is another
car in front of us
and if we press the arrow keys
something strange happens
we are not controlling our car anymore
we are controlling the other car and
that's because
the key listeners are being overwritten
from the original car to the last car in
the traffic
we're gonna need to specify which car
gets these controls and which not
so i'm going to go up here and tell this
car
to have here
keys
and i'm going to say this one
to be just a dummy maybe we will have it
move slowly or stand still or or
something like that dummy cars will have
some very simple behavior and now we are
going to go to car js
and in the constructor here i'm going to
also pass
control type so either keys or dummy
and i'm going to pass this to the
controls as well
and in controls js
this constructor will get a type like so
and here we are going to switch
according to the type
and we are going to say that
in case it was keys we are doing that
break
and in case this is a dummy i'm going to
set forward to
true
and break now i save this refresh
and the car in front
the car in front moved and
i actually can't catch it
because we have the same movement speed
i mean
max speed so it would be nice to go here
in the car constructor
and maybe specify here a value for this
max speed
let's have it default to three
but allow
us to change it
from the main file so in main.js here
i'm going to set a value of
2 for the dummy
save this refresh
and now i can actually
catch that
dummy
so far the sensors are not reading this
dummy car and we're not even getting
damaged by it
we'll take care of that in a sec but
first this scene is becoming a bit too
crowded with all these lines and the
dummy car doesn't really need a sensor
so i'm going to disable this by
going to our car js
and
if
control type
is not
dummy
then we will equip this car with the
sensor
and later
where we update the sensor
we will check
if
this
sensor exists
and only then update it and same goes
down below
for the drawing so if
there is a sensor
then we are going to draw it
and now
if i refresh that car in front doesn't
have any sensors doesn't draw any
sensors
it's just a dummy going at a fixed max
speed there on the road let's interact
with it i'm gonna go here in main.js
and where we update
here our car i'm also going to pass
the traffic
and because i'm going to write some
general code here
this is going to
be needed here
in the traffic update as well but i'm
just gonna pass nothing here because if
i do pass traffic here then that means
that the car in traffic is going to
interact with itself so it's just gonna
get damaged by
itself and i would need to write some
code to prevent that i'm also thinking
about later when we do some more complex
simulations and we have a bunch of cars
i don't want to have a lot of broken
down cars on the road and blockades so
i think that i don't want the traffic to
get damaged when it's touching other
traffic or
us so i'm leaving it empty here in case
of the traffic i'm saving this file and
then i'm going to our car
and in our update method here i'm going
to pass
traffic as well
and this is going to be needed
inside the asses damage here we will
assess damage with the traffic as well
but also
in the sensor update the sensor will
perceive the traffic as well let's do
this assess damage first it's quite easy
i'm going to pass
traffic
and i'm just going to copy this code
and replace here road borders with
traffic
and here
road borders with traffic of i
dot
polygon i think it's right
i save this
refresh and now when i press up
i'm catching catching catching that car
and when we collide i'm damaged it's not
damaged because our car is not in its
traffic list but feel free to play with
the code then make it like that if you
wish
now let's do the sensors as well so the
sensor update here
gets the traffic i'm gonna go now to
sensor js
and pass
the traffic here as well and also to
this
get reading here let me just write it a
bit
nicer so you can see this on screen
like so and the get reading
has now a traffic to deal with as well
so our touches the things that the rays
are going to intersect
may be
road borders but now polygon segments
from the traffic cars let's do this
i'm gonna go here below
and i will say
i
going through the
traffic like this
i will get a poly i'm doing this just so
that i don't repeat traffic of i dot
polygon everywhere
and now i'm going to
go
through
all of the points in that polygon
and get an intersection value using our
utility function
from
ray of zero and ray of one so this is
the same as there but here we are going
to take
the polygon j point
and j point plus one with our modulo
trick now if there is a value here then
we add it
to our touches as well
and that's it let's save and test
okay
because the traffic cars are black and
my ray turns black
as it touches the nearest segment of its
polygon
i don't see things very clearly
let me color the cars differently so
that our car is blue and
the traffic is red
i'm gonna go in main.js
and here let's draw this one as
blue and the traffic
as
red
like this and inside car js
i'm going to go down
to our draw method here
and say color and the non-damaged color
is going to be
[Music]
color
we save this
refresh
and now
we can actually see that ray
turning
black like that and our sensors are
reading that there is something in front
of it
and they are working from all different
angles
let me try a trick i saw once in uh
what was it fast and furious maybe
it was much better in that movie
okay
it went right through us
we now have a complete simulation a
drivable car with sensors that can see
the road borders and other cars in
traffic but so far we've been doing the
driving and that's about to change
next i'll give you a brief lesson in how
our brains work and then i'll show you
how to code something similar an
artificial neural network
you'll learn the components of this kind
of network and how to connect it to the
car so it can move by itself
neural networks are computing systems
inspired by the biological neural
networks in our brain
these are some neurons
these branch-like structures receive the
signals
when stimulated enough a neuron will
fire a signal through its axon
so a single neuron does something really
simple and intelligence only comes when
they work as a team
you see your brain has 86 billion
neurons
you also have quite many of them in your
spinal cord than sensory organs like in
your eyes and ears
these sensors send signal to some
neurons that pass it to the brain
there the processing happens like a
chain reaction where some neurons fire
some don't eventually signals arriving
to motor neurons that pass them through
your spinal cord and make some muscles
contract in very specific ways
hey
a lot happened in just a split second
let me try to slow this down and explain
it to you
pay attention
sensors inside the ear pick up
compression waves from the air and send
signals to the brain which figures out
the direction based on different
intensities
signals then travel to neck muscles tell
them to contract and turn the head in
that direction
the eye catches a glimpse of what's
happening and new signals travel to the
brain
peripheral vision is blurry but good
enough information exists to detect some
kind of object approaching and new
signals travel to facial muscles to
contract and protect the eyes from
getting hurt
eyes are really important
at the same time the brain begins a kind
of defense protocol by sending signals
throughout the body
time passes and the image becomes more
clear the brain does pattern matching
and recognizes the object as a ball
contextual and historical information
will play an important role in what
happens next
let's stick to the first one
the brain concludes there is no threat
and uses knowledge about physics it
learned during its lifetime to predict
where the object is headed it then sends
new signals to the muscles to contract
in slightly different ways to catch the
object instead of blocking it and the
rest is history one history where the
brain did a good thing and not much
happens afterwards but sometimes this
happens and the brain learns it did
something wrong and configures itself so
the same thing doesn't happen again
hopefully
anyway i'm feeling really good about
myself now that i know my brain can do
something like that in an instant
hope you do too
our car's neural network will do
something like that
neurons on the first layer will be
connected to the sensors
they will send signals forward a few
times and the last layer will be
connected to the car controls to make it
actually do something
spoiler alert will be working with
relatively small networks here but
that's okay because we actually don't
need very large networks to solve this
problem
now implementing all this in one shot is
well
scary
but it's easier if you break it into
levels like a building
each level has a floor a ceiling and
connections in between
the ceiling of one level is the floor of
the next and so on
now let's start to code one of these
levels i'm gonna go in index.html and
include a new file here let's call it
network js
and create the file here like this
inside the file we begin to write our
level class
and a level has a layer of input neurons
and a layer of output neurons
their numbers doesn't necessarily
match so i'll specify these parameters
here like this
to define the actual neurons we use
simple arrays of values
like this
we need one for the inputs
and one for the outputs
and i'll also add one for the biases
each output neuron has a bias a value
above which it will fire
so i'm defining these as an array like
this
now when coding this i'm actually going
to connect every input neuron to every
output neuron that's not the case in our
biological brains but these connections
will have weights
so a weight of zero means pretty much
the same thing
so let's have here
weights
equals to an empty array and going
through
all of the inputs
i'm going to
prepare here
an empty array
the size of the output count
so for each input node i'm gonna have
output count number of connections and
now what we have here so far is actually
only a shell for the brain to function
these weights and biases need to be set
to some real values
so for that i'm actually going to simply
randomize for now we're going to have a
random brain to begin with
and to randomize i'm actually going to
define a static method here this is
different from what we usually do but we
do it because i want to serialize this
object afterwards and methods don't
serialize
so
here given a level i'm going to go
through its
inputs like this
and for each input i'm going to go
through its outputs like this
and for every input output pair i'm
going to set the weight
to a random value between -1 and 1. and
to do that i'm gonna write here
math.random which gives us a value
between zero and one
multiply this by two so now we have a
value between zero and two
and subtract one
and now we have a value between minus
one and one
and actually biases are going to be in
the same range as well you may wonder
why negative values and here's one
reason for it
think what should happen here
the car sees something with the front
sensor so it should turn to avoid
collision
but which way
negative weights connected to these
sensors on the right could send the
message that don't turn to the right
so the remaining option is to turn left
both weights and biases can be between
-1 and 1 and there is a nice
mathematical reason for this which i
will explain soon
now these inputs they will be the values
that we get from the car sensors
and what we need to do is compute the
outputs using these weights and biases
that we defined those are random for now
but in a smart brain they will have some
kind of structure
we compute the output values using a
feed-forward algorithm and
it's actually quite simple
given some inputs these given inputs and
i'm passing here the level as well
i'm going to go through all of the level
inputs
and i'm first going to just set them to
these given inputs these will be the
values that come from the sensor
so we do that using a simple for loop
like this
and now to get the outputs we are going
to loop through every output
like this
and we are going to calculate some kind
of sum between the value of the inputs
and the weights i'll show you
so this sum is 0 in the beginning and
now we are going to use another variable
j to loop through the inputs like this
and the sum will actually add
the product between the jth input
and the weight between the joint input
and the id output like so and we repeat
this with every input neuron so
in the end what we will have to do
is check is this sum greater than the
bias of this output neuron
and if so we are going to set the output
neuron to one so we are essentially
turning it on
otherwise
the output neuron is going to be set
to zero
it's as simple as that and now i just
want to
close this and
return here
the outputs for convenience and i need
to also close this
level class right here now this code
will work and we'll leave it as such but
i'm gonna tell you a story and it's a
bit scary so brace yourself
you see scientists like to write it by
adding the bias here and comparing with
zero
because biases can go either way any
structure implemented like this can be
implemented this way as well
and this what we have now is the
hyperplane equation
[Music]
don't be scared
you see in a very very simple network
this is the line equation
a very simple function
the one and only weight here controls
the slope and the bias controls the
y-intercept
have a function like this for each
output
these neurons will fire if the value of
the function is above zero and with
weights and biases between -1 and 1 you
can implement any situation
that's why that range
now when you have two sensors you have a
plane in 3d space
think about a plane that goes out of
water like this
if the value of the two sensors is on
dry land then the neuron will fire
when you add more sensors you have
higher dimensions that are harder to
visualize
but the math still works and you can
have as many sensors as you want
i could go on with this story for hours
and tell you that scientists don't use
binary values here but instead allow
neurons to fire all the time just at
different amounts
i mean it happens here for these first
ones so why not for the other ones as
well
only the last ones need to be binary to
give you a clear yes or no answer but
networks are more powerful if these are
left as such
actually
not exactly as such because the values
here tend to go a bit out of control and
a more complex function is often used to
bring them back to scale
now the story may turn into an actual
horror if i start to tell you about what
the layers actually do
moving from linearly separable cases to
non-linearly separable ones and fine
fine i stopped this now
but if you want to experiment with
things like that you probably want to
try some kind of library
like tensorflow and there are actually
more of them out there
also let me know if you're ready for
more advanced content like this and
maybe i'll make it someday
meanwhile i recommend three blue one
brown's video on neural networks it
focuses more on the mathematics and uses
things like vectors matrices and other
things that tend to scare students off
for some reason i try to avoid these
here but if you plan to master machine
learning someday you're gonna have to
learn them
sorry
now let's get back to completing our
neural network code so far we have just
one level let's go now up here in the
beginning and define a neural network
made out of many of these
so i'm going to say here class neural
network
like so
and the constructor is going to get
an array of neuron
counts
so this is going to be the number of
neurons in each layer
and i will define here the levels i'm
going to make my neural network out of
an array of levels those we defined
earlier
and
for each level i'm going to specify
the input and output count like this
so
i'm adding here
a new level
with the
neuron counts from the height index and
the neuron counts from the i plus one
index
that's it simple as that
and here we're going to need a feed
forward algorithm as well
and this is also going to be really easy
so in the same way given inputs and the
network
i'm going to get the outputs by calling
the feedforward
method from the level
with the given inputs and the network's
first level like so
so this is now calling the first level
to produce its outputs
but then
i'm going to loop through the remaining
levels so notice that here i'm starting
at i equals to 1.
so looping through the remaining levels
like this i'm going to update these
outputs
with the feed forward result
from
the level i
like this
let me close this
return the final outputs
and we are done with the feedforward
method and with the neural network
object
so what we're doing here is essentially
putting in the output of the previous
level into the new level as the input
and the final outputs will tell us if
the car should go forward backward to
left or right
now let's connect this network to our
car sensors so i'm going to go to car
here
all the way up in the constructor and
where we're saying
that we define sensors for our car i'm
also going to say this dot brain is
equal to new
neural network
and
here we have to specify our array of
neuron counts the size of the layers
so in the first layer we're going to
have
this dot sensor dot
array count
and here you can have as many layers as
you want but i'm just going to add two
of them
one hidden layer
and the output layer which will have
four neurons one for forward one for
backward one for left and one for right
let's close this like so
and now
after we update the sensor here i'm
going to
first take out the offsets from the
sensor readings
remember our readings had three things
an x a y
and the offset of where the reading was
and from each sensor reading let's call
it s
i'm going to check if it is null then
i'm just going to return zero there's no
reading here the sensor goes as far as
possible and doesn't see anything
otherwise i'm going to return here 1
minus the sensor
offset
i'm doing this because i want our
neurons to receive low values if the
object is far away and higher values
close to one if the object is close
kind of like this flashlight
when we point it at the wall we see the
light coming back at us
and if we get closer the light that
bounces back is stronger
that's how sensors work in practice
now to see what the neural network has
to say we just say
outputs is equal to neural network
feed forward
these offsets
with this brain
and i'm going to log here these outputs
to test for now if i save the file and
refresh the page i'm gonna get there at
the bottom in the console
some array of values four values
one for forward one for left one for
right and one for backwards so at the
moment the car should actually go
forward left and right at the same time
but it can't do that because the brain
is not yet connected to the controls
it's kind of like when i had a knee
surgery a while back and they paralyzed
me from the waist down
while the anesthetic was wearing off i
really tried moving my feet the rain was
working normally but motor neurons were
just not sending the signals properly
to make the car do its own decisions we
are going to
go here in main js
and instead of using the keys to control
the car let's write here
a i for artificial intelligence
i'm going to save this file and in car
js
up in the constructor i'm going to
define here an attribute called
brain
that is going to be equal to control
type
double equals ai so if our control type
is ai it means that the brain that the
car actually has already is going to be
in use
so
down here in update
if this brain is in use
we are going to say the controls forward
is going to be equal to outputs of zero
controls left is going to be equal to
outputs of one
controls right is going to be equal to
outputs of 2 and controls
reverse i think it was
is equal to outputs of 3. let me just
check this real quick
yes it's reverse
saving this file refresh the page
and
nothing happens but if you look in the
output you'll see that this array has
four zeros in it so nothing is on
forward reverse left or right nothing is
pressed let's try to refresh again
remember these networks are random so
we can get anything out of this
okay
this was interesting so we have their
write and reverse turned on so this was
a card that just went backwards and to
the right
okay here we have a car going
forwards
left and in reverse so the forward and
reverse actually cancel each other out
and the car is standing still
okay
now this is really interesting we have a
car that goes forward so it went forward
in the beginning but look what happens
now
when those two sensors are touching the
car in front the network somehow
triggers the brake
it's amazing this was randomly generated
and we were lucky to get the really nice
behavior out of this
so our car is applying the brake every
time it gets really close to the other
car and just out of luck it's not
colliding with it so it's doing this
kind of
stalking motion there
now this debugging here is not really
very useful printing out the outputs
like this
and actually debugging things like this
is really hard you could go here and say
for example
car.brain
and
look at it and see that yes it does have
these
two levels that we defined previously
and the first level has
some inputs some biases
so we have the inputs here you can see
zero zero zero for the middle ones and
some values for the first and the last
one which is great
we visually see that one as well and the
outputs should be
for the first
level here
one one and all the other ones are zero
but then the second level is going to
get those inputs the one one zero zero
zero zero and
this network with these biases
random values between minus one and one
and these weights also many many random
values between -1 and 1 produce the
result that you see here so going
forward and reverse and left and right
everything just cancels each other out
in our car with all this brain
does nothing
so you can see how debugging like this
is very very difficult and we don't
really
get the full picture unless we really
start to analyze all these numbers here
and that's why it's going to be really
great when we visualize something here i
mean make something that at a glance we
can see this entire network in action so
i'm going to go to
index.html here and i'm actually gonna
refactor things a bit this my canvas
from the beginning is gonna be called
car canvas like this and we're gonna use
another canvas on the right to display
the network
so we're gonna visualize a neural
network in this one
now let me save this and go to our css
file
and my canvas will be renamed to car
canvas and i'm going to copy this
as
network
canvas and to distinguish between them
let's make this background black
like this
now in main js
i'm going to go here at the top and say
that this all we did so far is on the
car canvas and i'm actually gonna
refactor everywhere it says canvas here
by pressing right click
rename symbol
and saying here
car
canvas
like this and this ctx is going to be
renamed to car
ctx
like this
and i'm going to copy this part right
here
for the network canvas so here we have
network canvas
and network canvas
and here also network canvas
and i think this one can be a little bit
wider let's see if we can fit 300 pixels
white canvas next to our car canvas from
previously then here the car context is
gonna need
a network context next to it so network
context coming from our
network canvas
right
and one more thing we need to do here
when we make our car canvas have the
same size as the screen vertically i'm
gonna do the same thing for our network
canvas
save the file
refresh the page
and
we have our car on the left doing
something whatever it's doing and every
time we refresh it's probably gonna do
something different
probably not something smart
and on the right we have a blank black
canvas that also stretches quite nicely
with the size of the screen
and what will be really great is if you
can go here after drawing all the car
related stuff and saying visualizer
draw me a network
on the network context
and put there the car brain
like this
and now i'm actually going to add some
code here that does the visualization
for us
i'm not teaching it here because i think
we would be side tracking too much
but it's really well described on my
channel and their source code in the
description
so
saving everything
refresh the page
and
we have a network that decides our car
should go in reverse
quite boring let's try refreshing again
this network says it should go forward
left and in reverse
so basically it stands still
forward right and reverse
right then reverse
that was kind of interesting
one more thing is that this
visualization also supports animation so
we could animate this visualizer if you
want by going here and specifying a time
argument this value comes from the
request animation frame method here
and here we can say
network
ctx
dot line dash
offset
is equal to
time
and when we do this
oh boy okay this is a bit too fast let's
slow down this a bit by dividing here by
50.
and actually this animation should go
the other way around so i'm going to
specify here
minus time divided by 50. and now it's a
visual reminder that this is
implementing the feed forward algorithm
testing here one by one these randomly
generated networks and expecting some
miracle
is not very convenient
so let's write some code to parallelize
this and have many cars running
simultaneously like in different
parallel
i'm going to define here
a function called
generate
cars
that accepts n as the argument
and i'm going to have an empty array of
cars at first
and then
for i from 1 to n i'm going to push a
new car into this
array and the car is going to be
centered in the middle lane
at 100 y with 30 width and 50 height
like so
and they are all going to be ai cars
and here i just return these cars like
so and up here where we have
car defined we are actually going to
define
cars
instead
equal to
generate
cars of n like this and our n is equal
to
100
so we are going to have 100 cars going
in parallel and hopefully one of them is
going to do something right
we need to
update these cars here so where we have
here car dot update we are going to
write a loop and say
let i is equal to 0 i is less than cars
dot length
i plus plus
and then we have here cars of i
update
like so
and we're gonna do the same for the
drawing down here
drawing them
[Music]
as blue
like this but we still have two
individual car
objects here from previously
and i only need one car here so let's
just replace it with the first car in
the array for now
otherwise this code will not work
so this is for translating the canvas on
one car from the 100 and this is just
printing the brain of this one car
somewhere on the right
save the file refresh the page
and wow
it's a total mess
one thing we can do to make this nicer
is actually draw them semi-transparent
so i'm going to go here and say
car ctx dot global alpha is equal to 0.2
and after i'm done drawing these cars
i'm going to set global alpha back to
one so it doesn't affect what i'm gonna
be drawing afterwards or on the next
frame
so saving this and refreshing
it's a little bit better but still quite
much happening there
i think that i want to emphasize one car
like for example
the zeroth car this one that we are
using
everywhere
pretty much by drawing it again with the
maximum
opacity
but also i want this one to be the only
car for which we draw the sensors
so i'm going to modify this draw method
of the car next
and say here
a third parameter
for draw sensor this is by default set
to false
and here
if this sensor exists
and
draw a sensor
only then we are going to draw its
sensor and now it's a little bit clearer
not so many yellow lines there
and
you can see something interesting
already that this car right here car
zero is not the most
interesting one the most interesting one
went somewhere up there and it was
chasing the other red car so back to
main js
here our cars of zero choice is not
really great we want to focus on the
best car the one that goes upwards the
most or the one with the minimum y value
and i'm going to define this best car
here and say
best car
is equal to find the car
whose y value
is equal to
the minimum value
okay
of
all the y values
of the cars
so this may seem a little bit scary
so what is happening here
cars.map
c
going to c dot y this means that we are
creating a new array with only the y
values of the cars that's it
and here we are spreading this array
because the math min method here doesn't
work with the arrays it works with many
many different values no matter how many
you want to pass it but not with actual
arrays and that's where we need to
spread it here and we just find the car
whose y value is the minimum value of
all the y values the code is not really
complicated but if you're not used to
this modern syntax then this can be a
little bit daunting at first i added
here because you will see it if you work
with javascript so now with this best
car i'm going to copy it everywhere we
were using cars of xero previously so we
translate the canvas to the best cars
y like this
and then here we are drawing
the best car without transparency so
that we clearly see it and with the
sensors
we are also drawing the brain
of this best car
and that's it i'm gonna save this
and refresh
and now our canvas is always centered on
the car that goes
upwards the most in this case these
stalking cars that are behind this red
one
all right let's try to refresh again
and again
i'm waiting for a card that passes this
red car but then continues to go in a
straight line somehow so just by trial
and error i think that we're going to be
able to get to something like that let's
see
okay
we got something it's uh
fidgeting quite a lot but definitely
better than all other cars we had so far
it passed the car in the traffic and
it's just going forward forever pretty
much but now the problem is that when i
leave the browser this car is going to
be gone and all my experimenting was for
nothing so let's write some code to save
this car
i'm going to use local storage for this
so i'm going to say
local storage
set item
the best brain that we have so far we're
gonna store it in this best brain
attribute in local storage
and
the value is going to be
a json string coming from the best cars
brain so i'm essentially serializing
that brain into local storage
and come to think of it we might need to
destroy this saved brain as well so i'm
going to discard maybe it's a better
word
the value from local storage with this
other function i'm sure it's going to be
needed sooner or later
now this best car is actually not
accessible here so let me
just
update its value here but define it here
as a global variable
like
this i'm using lit because it's changing
and i'm gonna set it to be the first car
in the beginning but it's gonna update
on every frame
now
if we have in local storage
a brain a best brain stored i'm going to
set the brain of this best car
to the value and i'm using json parse
because i am parsing the json string we
saved previously local storage only
works with strings
like this
now in index.html
i'm going to put these buttons
vertically between the two canvases
so here i'm going to use a div to define
vertical
buttons with id vertical buttons
and i'm going to say here the first
button is going to have an on click of
save
like this
and our second button is going to have
an on click
of this card
like so
and here i'm actually going to use
emojis for these button contents
like this with the save icon and a trash
icon you can find emojis like this just
by searching online so i'm going to save
this file and go to the css next
and remove this text line from the body
because we're going to use
flex display instead
so i'm going to remove this
and say
display flex
justify content and align items to
center
like this
and now
our vertical buttons are going to go
here
with display flex and flex direction
column so this is by default row
and making it column means that our
buttons will go below each other and
here we define our button next
so i like to remove the border and give
it a round
shape so a radius there
and a padding this is some value that i
found goes nicely with the emojis that
we use and the margin of two pixels
and the cursor is set to pointer so that
our
arrow icon changes into a hand cursor
when the mouse is over it and speaking
of hovering with the mouse let's set a
hover for the button so that it gets a
blue background like this so save the
file
refresh the page
and looks like we have another shaky car
over here but we are not going to lose
it this time because we can press the
save button and this means that now
inside of our local storage we have this
car's brain
so now when i'm gonna refresh the page
what it means is that here inside of
main js where we are loading the value
from local storage we still get the car
from previously
now what we're doing here could be
actually fully automated so that the
computer tries again and again and
always keeps the best but let's think
about what the goal is
i mean what will a good network be able
to do
let's look at the definition of the best
car here
we're just using the y-coordinate but
you can use other functions here as well
these are called fitness functions
for example you could measure the travel
distance instead
doing that may result in cars that go
backwards as a easy way to avoid the
obstacles
or just go around in circles forever
going infinitely far but also going
nowhere at the same time
so need to be careful when choosing a
fitness function
i'm using the y value here but if the
road would be turning it wouldn't work
anymore
so think about these and play around
with the code
and try to think about other stuff as
well like could you come up with a
fitness function that keeps rewarding
the car for going upwards but penalizes
for going too much sideways or even
better penalizes if you're not in the
center of the lane
these are all homework ideas for you but
now i think we're ready for more traffic
let's go here in our traffic array
put a coma at the end
and add two more cars
one is gonna be
on lane 0
and minus say
300 and the other one at the same
vertical level
but lane
2.
i'm going to save this
refresh and now let's see what happens
almost there
but it looks like even our shaky car
didn't make it so let's try again
it looks like there are just not enough
cars passing that first car in traffic
what we would like to have is more cars
like this shaky car
but not exactly like it so that one of
them maybe is gonna stand a chance and
pass the second and third car in the
traffic
so let's go now to network js
and i will teach you how to mutate a
network
and it may sound fancy but it's really
really easy i'll show you
we write here a method called mutate
which takes a network as a parameter
and an amount let's default this to 1 or
one hundred percent this will just
randomize everything what we had
previously but if you set this value to
like ten percent then you're going to
get the network that is
close to the original one that we pass
it here so how does this work
well
we are going to go through all the
levels of the network using a for each
loop like this
and for each level
i'm going to use this arrow function
notation here
i'm going to iterate
through all the biases
and then through all the weights later
but first with the biases
and i'm going to say that the i bias
is going to be equal to
lerp we're going to use linear
interpolation again
and i will interpolate between the
current value of the bias whatever that
is
and
a random value between minus one and one
as we did in the randomizing but now we
are using lerp to go from the current
value of the bias towards whatever that
random value is
depending on this amount right here
as simple as that and i'm just going to
repeat the same thing for all the
weights so i just go
through all the
ij
weights
like this
and say that
those weights
that weight of i and j is going to be
equal to
linear interpolation
between
the current value of the weight
and
a value between -1 and 1 a random value
and again depending on this amount
so if this amount is going to be
let me see did i close this properly
no
so if this amount is going to be 100
then we just get this part right here
and this mutate is pretty much our
randomized method that we had previously
here for a level
but now it works for the entire network
so
if the amount is zero then our biases
and our weights just stay the same but
if this value is somewhere in between
then it's gonna move away from these
biases depending on this amount
so let me save this file now and go back
to main.js
where we are
reading the brain from the local storage
here
and actually we are going to loop
through all the cars
and say
let i is equal to 0 less than
cars.length
i plus plus
so for each car here
cars of
i
its brain is going to become
equal
to that from the local storage
so
this as such is going to be really
really boring right because it means
that if we refresh now we just see 100
cars that are overlapping each other and
they're
that are acting exactly the same
but i'm going to put here a condition
and say that if i is not zero so
the brain that we have in local storage
will be kept for
the case when i is zero and that is our
best car initialization there
but for all the other ones i'm going to
mutate and say neural network
dot mutate
the car
of i
brain
by an amount let's say
0.1
and now let's see what happens
you can see many cars this time but they
are all following our shaky car quite
closely
and this one none of them was able to go
beyond that
second car in traffic let's try again
nope it looks like this 0.1 might be too
low basically our new networks are too
similar to the one that we already have
in memory so let's try 0.2
now our cars look a little bit more
different than before but still quite
similar to our shaky car and look at
that we have a new best car
maybe
i hope it doesn't hit the border now yes
it figured out it has to turn that's
great so i'm going to save this new car
right now
and when i'm gonna refresh
now our new car the more improved car
which wasn't even shaking is stored in
memory and it's going to mutate and try
to become even better if possible but
our scenario now with three cars is not
a match anymore so we can try even
harder one
let's go here and copy this
maybe
four more times
and
here let's have two cars at
-500 and the last at minus
700
and we are going to have here maybe
on lane 0 and lane 1 and then on lane 1
and lane 2. so i'm just thinking how to
make a complicated scenario that
involves all kinds of twists and turns
so let's save this and refresh
and now let's see what happens
oh okay
i'm gonna save this
phew i did it before this other boring
car overtook it so
that's something that you may want to
pay attention to
let's refresh
ah
nothing
i think we want a lower value for the
mutation here
so that more cars are going to be like
that one that almost went
past these other two cars
you can see quite many of them here now
still nothing let's try again
okay this is interesting
i would say this is a new winner now
it got to this stage and now it's going
in line with the other cars let's save
it
it's taking too long let me try with
1000 cars
i think this should work on my computer
if your computer is too slow then just
stick with 100 cars and repeat more
ah almost there
yes yes we did it we did it oh no no no
no no no no
ah i should have saved that one i think
it could have mutated into something
good eventually
huh
let me save this it's clearly better
come on i'm hopeful that this time we're
gonna make it
let's see
okay two cars there now
will one of them stop before hit
yes
yes
that car stopped just before hitting the
sides there let me save this
try again
and now we have quite many of them that
are quite similar
okay let's keep just one car here and
see it in action without any other
things disturbing it
okay that was quite
quite close there
oh
yes
somehow i thought it's going to get
damaged even though i know that it's the
best car from previously so it won't get
damaged
there are many more sophisticated
genetic algorithms out there
for example some algorithms use
crossover so they take two networks and
mush them together somehow
the hope is that maybe one car knows how
to turn left really well and another one
knows how to turn right so combining
these networks could give you a new one
that can do both
think you can implement this
if you got this far i think you can try
it out and let me know how it went
we are now actually done
i won't be teaching you any more
algorithms you have many things you can
play around with
and i'm quite happy with the car we have
right now it's making its own decisions
and it's avoiding all other cars
it could be better like if it would
recognize the lanes but i'll let you
worry about that
meanwhile i'm gonna relax and show you
how to draw a car in powerpoint
since you got this far all i can say is
congratulations
hope you took things seriously and by
now you've learned how to simulate
driving mechanics detect collisions and
create artificial sensors
you also know about neural networks what
they can do and how to optimize them
using a simple genetic algorithm
but we just scratched the surface here
and i haven't really taught you why the
neural network works
i mean sure we built one and because
it's so complex you can assume some
smart behavior is possible but how does
it really work
we have such a great system now that
it's a shame to put it to waste
so i'm thinking about making a new
course where we start off with the very
simple network and gradually go bigger
and bigger and see what each of them can
do
we could also try new things like
teaching the car to stop before impact
how to respect the lanes maybe even how
to park and other cool stuff like that
what do you think would you like a
course like that to practice even more
javascript and become a master of making
diagrams that show what's inside these
so-called black boxes
and if you want something else right now
i do have a lot of content on youtube
this course teaches how to build
location-based applications in this one
we make an augmented reality piano
and here we use the camera to make a new
kind of puzzle game
i have many small projects as well but
really hard to keep track
maybe they're better organized on my
website i don't know
by the way on the website you can find a
more enhanced version of the
self-driving car check it out if curious
anyway thanks for watching
please share this course with anyone you
think is interested and since you got
this far you're probably subscribed
already so
see you guys
you